100% of humans are replaced every 100
years and we continue on as a species
cuz we learn from others so have you
ever heard if you want it done right do
it yourself no one can do it like I do
it nobody can replace me I'm
irreplaceable those are incorrect
beliefs about how to do business replace
it with these thoughts and these
thoughts have served me well if you want
it done right get someone to spend all
their time doing it if I can do it
someone else can do it better than M
everyone is replaceable especially M
because even if you are better than them
spending 100% of your time you're not
going to cuz you got other you're
going to do if you own the business so
it makes sense that even if somebody's
half as good as you if they spend 100%
of their time they still probably do a
better job and if you still don't think
they're better than you I'll bet you 20
of them are right